non-minimalists
nick wants to know once you declutter
how do you keep from the clutter coming
back
[Laughter]
so so this is a fascinating question
because i mean the typo notwithstanding
but um there's almost like a freudian
slip there right right
but the people often think of
minimalism as a destination
but minimalism is not the destination
minimalism is
the vehicle that's not my pithy answer
but you can tweet that podcast sean
damn and so i i want you to think about
it this way
what ryan and i use minimalism force to
live a more deliberate life
that includes with less stuff but there
are times
where ryan and i we still have to bring
new things into
our life we do so deliberately but over
time sometimes those things stop adding
value
and so when they stop adding value we
have to be
willing to let go here's a pithy answer
for you the most effective way to
declutter
is to leave the junk at the store
and so there's always going to be a
point where you have to continue
to declutter it's probably not going to
be the same volume if you're one of
those people
like the average american who has 300
000 items in their house i know because
i was one of them
when you get started you're going to be
decluttering a lot but even once you've
reached the point of decluttering or
maybe even you could say you're a
minimalist
there's going to be a point where you
start to let go of stuff new things that
come in
so always be willing to let go nick well
our circumstances constantly change
right yes so you might
like mariah and i live in a studio
apartment right now right
uh eventually we'll have kids and we'll
have another bedroom
so we'll need things for that child and
for that
bedroom for like for the kid totally so
um
yeah uh like you said minimalism is not
a destination it is a tool
used to live a deliberate life so
don't um don't beat yourself up if if
you get a little bit of clutter in your
life that that's okay
that's that's why you have minimalism in
your life it's so you can handle it as
you start to notice it i know like i was
watching uh
i don't know a few months back i was
watching hoarders yeah and
it made me question everything i had and
i
but i did i looked at our bookshelf i'm
like i have a bookshelf
and it's full because it's there and my
my rule is is like oh we don't
you know we don't have more books than
can fit on the bookshelf
but even that i'm like that's still kind
of silly so i got rid of half the books
and now half of it's empty and
yeah it actually aesthetically looks uh
pretty good and you're no longer a
secret order that's right exactly
um here's my pithy answer a life without
boundaries is a house without
walls so
yeah it's uh that doesn't exist it
doesn't exist
you you've got to have some boundaries
set up in life i mean the you know the
boundaries we
have in life um and just like walls in a
home it keeps
things from going out and it keeps
things from coming in it works both ways
so uh you've gotta have some boundaries
if not then you're gonna have a out of
control life
you know real quick before we move on to
our listener tips ryan i just wanted to
say that
there was something that that resonated
with me there when you were talking
about you and mariah and if you had kids
obviously you would
need to have another bedroom unless you
know you're just putting a crib in your
studio and that could work for a period
of time
it may not be ideal though and so
minimalism isn't about deprivation it's
about finding the most
ideal situation for you
and usually that means owning less but
in time
that might mean incorporating more into
your life as your
life changes and i think the prime
example here is if you go look at our
two documentaries
you look at our first one minimalism
which came out in 2016.
and we filmed it in 2014 so how old was
i then i was uh 32
at the time oh my god i'll be 40 this
year oh my goodness
right so so uh i'll be 40 this year and
if you look
at the the new documentary less is now
and you look at my home in that one
compared to my home
when i was single without a kid in
when i was 32 they're completely
different
right places and and so
it doesn't mean that one is more
minimalist than the other
it's there both are appropriate for that
stage of my life
and so when you compare the two it's not
equating them necessarily it's just
saying
this was appropriate for me then this is
appropriate for me now
as what is appropriate changes i need to
be willing to change
the things that surround me